Drake's in my feelings is still number
one on Billboard largely because of the
viral dance challenge that Shiggy
started when he posted the video of
getting out of his car and dancing to
Drake's track yeah the guys have met
since and people started to report the
Drake awarded should be two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for helping the
track go to number one well now Iggy now
asked Drake where's my money
my pleasure yo sup bro saying she gave
me 250 I don't know much check is that
though that I said cuz I when I call
universal they said like you know it's
international from Canada to New York
it's on the way so you know that you
were gonna started our room and [ __ ] and
I get my checking right now
I saw on the way baby you know I'm
saying this all the way okay so on this
way when the connects make that not you
know what happens when like I don't know
if you ever sent out a wire using out a
wire
yeah easily got to give me the two 5000
plus a set oh you gotta let that rule no
go away because I know you're not ending
that's crazy yeah I got you you got me
was that real no I think if they're both
joking about it cuz that was they're
very good at it maybe maybe you see it
was actually asking a Drake for his
money
turn surprised we've seen that before on
Instagram why here you get him live to
try to look like they might have been on
the set of a music video or something so
that could have been shooting the music
we defer my feelings because she's in
that video oh yeah maybe Drake should
give also the money the two hundred
fifty grand
that's sweet well I have no think he's
not actually baby couldn't give him that
money but you should give chicky
something I don't see he's got a lot of
like notoriety from this now but still
tricky got some money yeah anything his
own money you know if he wants to give
money to be nice it's a donation but no
him money I know but still you nice to
give Sunday fur do you mean he made this
song number one with like Drake having
to do nothing just sitting back and
watching these videos up and now Drake
created a song that made this guy famous
that's the reality it's not the other
way around but no one was gonna make
this song a single wasn't gonna go to
number one out in the world is I would
have found the world eventually but he
still made it this song made that guy
famous not the other way around
let's not forget let's not forget
alright